do you guys see how much money was made
during the pandemic anybody say how much
money was made during the pandemic just
how much criticism these people how this
billionaires became rich and all this
other stuff i'm gonna tell you why that
happened all the way at the end of it
but you got to figure out for yourself
where you are in this where you are with
the topic prior to this like who you
want to be how you want to make your
money now having said that let's go
there's a couple things we need to talk
about that's going on in america today
cody said patrick you know what i wonder
about your style
is when you speak it's like
you you you are comfortable being
controversial
and you touch certain topics but you
don't offend people but but you still
touch the controversial topics well i
have to touch a controversial topic
today so let's talk about it
there's a lady
named jane elliott anybody knows the
story who knows who jane elliott is
handful of you i love it let's get
controversial
jane elliott
a day after martin luther king
is assassinated
does an exercise
with her third graders because she's a
teacher
so one day she brings in her classmates
and she says
i just want everybody everybody to know
in this classroom here
if your eyes are blue
blue eyed people by study
are known to be better
smarter stronger and they have more
privileges than brown eyed
people and she says this to these third
graders by the way if she did that today
she'd be in jail for 20 years okay
okay
so
the kids are like
really
blue eyed people i'm brown
oh this sucks
so as she's watching all these kids day
one
they're doing an exercise and this one
brown eyed person doesn't understand one
of the formulas that she's given and the
blue-eyed kid says oh you don't
understand it oh that's right you're
brown-eyed
so the brown hat kid looks at him says
what'd you call me well you're brown
height us blue-eyed people are
privileged you're not
the brown eyed kid comes shoves the kid
fight breaks out
teacher comes the next day he says guys
i have to apologize i messed up what's
that
the study came back it's actually the
brown eyed people
that are more privileged than blue-eyed
people
and they get more privileges they're
smarter they're stronger by by a mile
they're just much stronger and smarter
my mistake blue i know you thought about
that's really the brown eyed people so
next thing you know the brown i was like
i told you you know it's like i'm the
brown eyed right the third graders and
the blue i don't oh
really yeah the blue eye you're not as
smart as a brown eye so what happens a
day goes by two days goes by one of the
kids starts calling one of the blue
white you're bluey you're a bluey
fight breaks out right you know third
graders will say the dumbest things to
each other right
next day she comes and she says kids
i've been lying the entire time to you
the world doesn't care whether you're
blue eyed or brown-eyed
nobody has privileges over you
you want to win big go make it happen
you want to learn you can nobody cares
about your color
your skin your ethnicity no body does
now
some of you
don't like this message
but this is coming from a guy who was
born and raised in iran who have been
called every single thing in the world
because i started off at morgan standing
dean with her day before 9 11 and we
know who did 9 11. it's from where i'm
from i remember one time i was speaking
in denver colorado the speaker his name
was jack
it's 06. i've never been introduced this
way before he says and the next speaker
we're bringing up one of the fastest
growing agents in all of america he's
doing stuff we've never seen before
his former occupation
is a pilot
he knows how to fly planes he just
doesn't know how to land planes help he
bring up patrick with david
did you get did you get it or no
so i come up i'm like okay now here's a
crazy thing i'm not offended i was in a
military my skin is so thick like when
people try to troll like do you realize
how bad we would have trolled you in the
army we would have destroyed you
psychologically you're so sensitive oh
my gosh
spend a month at our army unit people
are so weak nowadays i'm so sensitive so
where am i going with this with you let
me tell you where i'm going with this
and you here's my point to you listen
this is the problem we're all facing and
we have to overcome this number one
what is america doing today to us
exactly what i just shared with you
propagandas now propaganda is when i
explain it to you about to look at in a
completely different way what is the
definition of a propaganda here we go
information especially of a biased or
misleading nature used to promote or
publicize a particular political cause
or point of view in other words
manipulate
is that happening today to us yes or no
all right gas lighting what is gas
lighting here's gas lighting
manipulating someone by psychological
means into questioning their own sanity
like how many guys are sitting here like
maybe we are bad people
i mean i mean
we must because
798 people said in the last month on tv
oh my gosh babe we're such terrible
human beings babe
babe you know moving forward we have to
apologize to everybody we're such
terrible people what the hell you told
me we're terrible you know 99 of people
i meet in my life they're good people i
don't know if you know this or not 99 of
people i've met in my life are good
people black white hispanic asian
educated doesn't matter 99 of them are
good people but
this is effective so what does this do
both can be very effective way to shape
a population's mind and they're doing it
today and most are falling for now
parents what do they do similar things
they instill beliefs on us
i host a monthly webinar with uh certain
seals and founders around the world the
one i was doing two days ago one of the
guys good looking wiper looks like brad
pitt like almost too pretty one
chromosome away from being a girl like
he is way too pretty to be a guy so
he's talking his hey you know and he's
still like
quite like a little timid to himself but
all of a sudden he snapped he's got his
20 million here like he has nothing to
be embarrassed of he says you know what
patrick for the last three months and
the book you gave us to read you know
what it made me realize i said what
for 29 years i believe i'm shy i
went to my mom the other day i said mom
you f me up cause everybody you ever
introduced me to here's how you would
introduce me yes this is my son hunter
he's so shy
here's my son hunter he's so shy
okay you're my hero
i guess i'm shy
and then we act like we're shy
he's so shy he's so shy right
the other day i'm talking to my kids
and
you know they're doing jump ropes so
they're going doing jump ropes and
my younger one is better at jump rope
and all of a sudden the older one comes
and does it and we measure how many
times we can do because they can get a
toy if they hit a number everything in
our family is like performance-based
right so
the older one all of a sudden gets to
39. and the younger one has 28 dylan now
dylan's cavs if you ever see dylan's
caps it makes no sense right
so
i said to dylan look dylan here's how
this works
tico's stamina
you're fast but tico's stamina
meaning tico can run long distance but
you are fast
so i walked around and i think about
look at this parent look what i just did
right
a week later mario comes over and they
start doing the same thing says yeah you
know what my dad told me my dad said
tico's the one that can run long
distance but i'm shortened so i get
tired fast
and i caught him state i'm like oh
man you messed up
so i said let's go for a talk i said hey
let me tell you something i used to not
have stamina but i build it i'm one of
the most very few people can outglass
your daddy and i think you can do the
same as well you think so that of course
buddy absolutely you can do it as well
all right all right so the other night
we're laying down hey so who's smart in
this family tico like the older one i
said how about you no he's smarter i
said no i think you're very smart for
seven i wasn't smart like you at seven
you think i'm smart of course you're
smart
okay i'm smart now i don't say things
like
you can be anything you want to be in
life that's a lie
so i don't say stuff like that like hey
you can jump 46 inches no that's lebron
james at 680 265 pounds you may never
jump 46 inches body right your dad's
vertical leap is six inches you don't
have good genetics right so so
so i can't say anything because we can't
be anything it's a lie parents tell
right and quite frankly when one day you
realize you can't be anything it messes
with you a little bit then you have to
escape right so instill beliefs now
here's the thing we have to realize
these beliefs parents impose on us our
siblings
our friends
our spouses our bosses
some do it intentionally
most do it unknowingly like don't go
call your mom today say mom you suck
dad you screwed up
he knows we all screwed up as parents
you just want to screw up a little bit
less but
you have to be aware of this so today
we're having lunch and the conversation
starts with me tom and mario and sam
and i said let me ask you questions i'm
having this conversation by the way this
content we just came up with just so
everybody knows this part of what we
just came up with right now
so i'm talking i'm like so let me ask
you a question what did your mom tell
your dad tell you when you were a kid
that pissed you off so i go back like my
dad would always say patrick's lazy
pat's lazy my grades were lazy
everything was lazy i passed late so i'm
like i'm lazy okay i'm lazy i'm lazy i'm
lazy
how about yours and tom's like he's a
chatter chat or what i don't know
something shadow what's the word that
they call the chatter one
box so it's about chatterbox he's a
chatterbox so tom's like i said did you
like it he says honestly when my mom
introduced me like that to people i
talked i don't like that i said mario
how about yours and we're going through
the whole thing i said tell me about the
positive thing
and sam tells me about his mom what do
you what she said about him he didn't
his father died early when he was a kid
but he tells me about his father
and and mario tells me about his mom and
you know mario is this and tom's tells
me his thing i said you know what
happened with me i said you have no idea
how many of those moments i've had my
mom and my dad
you know some of them could be you know
all women are da da da you know men are
if your mom tells you a thousand times
men are that
you believe men are da da da
so if you got an argument with your
husband because your mom told you men
are that if you got an argument with
your wife because your dad told you
women are
right
so i said one day
i got so pissed off i said
i'm gonna create my own identity and
here's what it is you ready he said what
is that's at 23 years old
i said i'm gonna be known for this
when pat says something's gonna happen
it's done
i wanted everybody to say this was in
business with me
so i started doing it can you do this i
can't why not because if i say it and if
i don't do it then my reputation of pat
says something it's going to get done
goes lower i'd like to keep a score of
80 percent when i say i'm going to do
something 80 at a time guess what i want
to be done i want it to be done i want
that to be my reputation and i'm going
to create on myself
so so tom what you do yourself tom's
like
at 33 years old i created my own
reputation what was it
i leave people better than i found them
that's tom's mo everybody that ever
works with tom says tom leaves us better
than he found us
pat if he says something's gonna get
done gets done
i used this entire method of propaganda
and gaslighting on myself
because at that time when i said it was
a lie
but i said it so many times i guess what
happened all of a sudden if i say it's
gonna happen so it's a negative thing
but all of you in here can use us
positively now
your parents your boss
your peers your siblings your friends
have years of experience on you doing
this you got to change your reputation
the marketplace they're not going to do
it for you you got to go out there and
start saying i'm sorry what was that no
no
that's the 27 year old johnny let me
tell you what the 41 eurozone is known
for the 41 your john is known for that
that really yeah
i'm not laughing did you see me laughing
no no i'm not laughing i'm dead serious
oh bro i'm just like no i know that i
know like you like to say that all the
time you got to stop saying that cause
that was like 14 years ago bro i don't
live in the past you do can we move on
yes
all right okay cool you guys got to
stand up for yourself a little bit when
people do this to you now let me
continue let me continue
let me continue so now
someday you have to determine your own
identity and beliefs you gotta you gotta
dictate it you leave this place if this
is just another event you came here to
get a couple pieces of business
maybe meet somebody maybe network and
you leave and nothing changes about you
this was a waste of an event for you not
for everybody but for you
so you got to make some decisions here
now power words power words applies on
leadership persuasion selling
negotiation recruitment scripts
overcoming objections dealing with
underwriters dealing with insurance
companies it's all words so here's some
of the words i added to my repertoire
maybe could help you out as well
replace the word should with ought
stop telling people what they should do
that's not your business
tell them this is what you ought to do
because odd still gives me an out should
doesn't give me an out shoot is a
judgmental word art is not so replace
those two
request hey john can i make a request
yeah yeah pat what's going on i'd like
to see us improve in the following areas
man yep you know what pat we're going to
work on okay cool that's my request guys
can i make a request no right word
request request add it to your
repertoire next hey johnny can i make a
suggestion to you
yeah of course what's that so i can make
it to yeah
i don't know if i would put that desk
over there
why not here's why you know how people
enter whatever it is can i make a
suggestion to you next bobby if i were
you i would consider doing the following
but i'm not you but if i were you i
would do this but you got to do what you
got to do but if i were you i would do
dot dot
johnny do i have your permission to be
direct with you sure do i have your
permission yes hey babe yeah babe do i
have a permission to be direct with you
yeah of course what happened you know
the other day family was over and he
kind of joked about that one thing just
really bothered me
really bad i've been thinking about it
for it's been four days i'm still
thinking about it oh i'm so sorry babe
no it's okay but i just want to tell you
like moving forward like
that's got to kind of stop like it just
doesn't sit well with me i appreciate
you listening to me but you know i just
want to tell you that oh babe i'm so
sorry i'll work on a movement for you
thanks so much babe all good i'm gonna
go to dinner yeah
let's go to dinner right so boom
conversation now versus what though
the other day you make something
just you know maybe it's good for movies
but it's not good for marriage you know
when you're kind of lived to animate it
hey you know what i want you to consider
what's that i want you to consider doing
this consider has an out
ought has an out
suggest has an out request has an out
right let me get back to you a lot of us
want to give answers right now you would
save 80 of your arguments if you just
said to people at the end
hey johnny yeah um let me get back to
you
okay
yeah look just give me like a couple
days
all right cool you get back to them if
it's important to get back to you if you
make a note of you're going to get back
you've got two days to process the
decision whether you want to do it or
not but it's power of words right
let me make a case to you why you ought
to that i'm going to make a case to you
guys why you ought to make a lot of
money post pandemic really what is it
here's what it is i'm gonna make a case
to you why you ought to consider getting
an annuity right now i'm gonna make a
case to you why i want you to consider
this kind of an insurance policy okay
what is it here's my case and then you
go into your presentation right please
thank you
these words have power
a person wants to do business with you
if you use these magical words versus
somebody else who doesn't if you're in
the sales world you're dealing with
people or anything you're doing these
things will do wonders for you now let's
talk about dreams how many of have big
dreams let's see here now this time that
man with the arms across white shirt
glasses on he will not raise his hand is
that your husband by the way you're
elbowing him or no does he have dreams
or no
yes what's his name can you tell us his
name
bart
what's what's his last name tell me his
last name's not
what is it
okay no no it's not simpson right so
it's last name is what
hi bart
my buddy bart okay
let's talk about dreams
here we go
number one
serious question by the way just so you
know nobody cares if you get this answer
right or wrong
so you question
how many of you are 100 clear about your
dreams
and goes to the point that if i brought
you up you can recite it in 20 seconds
everybody would believe you
[Laughter]
how many of you come on miss your hands
i can't this light is like a tanning bed
right here
how many guys how many guys are so chris
by the way i appreciate you for being
honest look by the way let me ask please
put your hands up and folks i actually
want you to look around how many of you
are so crystal clear by your dreams and
goals that you can go on stage and
explain it to everybody put your hands
up put it up high look around by the way
good to see you buddy you know good good
to see you look around look around look
don't look at me look around turn around
and look behind you look behind you how
few people's hands are up
okay so now great let's process this
so when it comes down to dreams i can
tell you most people are not that clear
we just kind of live our life he's like
i hope you know
now watch this some of you who are
anybody ever wonders why such a small
percentage of people's dreams become a
reality
anybody ever wonders that who wonders
that like why does such a small people
so i've asked this question on myself so
many times here's why
because we don't ask the second third or
the fourth question so what's the second
question here's the second question
your dreams that life you want to live
how demanding is that life
how demanding is that dream of yours
what does it require for you to do
is it a one year run
is it a three year run is it a 5 10 15
20 run what is it how demanding is it
we don't ask that question but some of
us do but the third one is where people
quit and nobody knows
no one knows why people's dreams don't
become a reality until the third
question you ready for the third
question
are you willing to meet that demand
you know there comes a time in your life
where you're kind of like ah
devon booker they asked him they said
how was he being in high school he says
honestly i never partied i don't know
how it was to party he says i practiced
in the morning
i went to school after school i had
double practice then i had another
league by the time i came home i was
done with my i was so tired my friends
wanted me go out i never had time to go
out
so then we see him in the finals
dropping 40 something points about to
win the finals and people wonder oh he
must be talented no no
he was willing to meet the demand
i wasn't willing to meet the demand in
high school
i wasn't look at my height
i have an athletic body i could have
played a lot of sports i wasn't willing
to meet the demand but nobody explained
this thing to me you think i'm going to
explain this thing to my kids when we
talk to them of course they're going to
answer this question very soon
they're gonna know whether they are or
they're not
many of us didn't know but now you do
so now some of you are like well my
dreams are pretty big
how demanding is it to have those dreams
become a real pretty big are you willing
to meet the demand
you know what i mean
i don't know
i know don't give me no 95 is i don't
know
believe me i know
you know what the last one is here's the
last one
when you close your eyes and you go
visualize that dream
does it make you emotional
do you actually cry about it
do you sit there and you say oh my gosh
if this were to ever become a reality
i would melt
i would melt how many guys can think
about your dreams and get emotional how
many guys can do that raise your hand if
you can do that now watch how many more
hands came up now i wonder why that
happens to you i wonder why that happens
if somebody told me says well pat
i'm making 400 000 a year i was a
butcher
i was a butcher but
i was a bartender making 65 000 a year
making 400. the hell am i doing working
80 hours a week again why would i do
that i said aha great question because
dreams are multi-dimensional and you've
only thought about one dimension what's
that i just explained this in aruba
remember a couple weeks ago we talked
about this and here's what it is
most of us we only think about dreams
from what perspective whose dreams ours
see it's multi-dimensional
first way we think about dreams are
our dreams
second way is your spouse's dreams ask
my wife one time babe what are your
dreams babe i want to be a poet
seriously
seriously you're not
you're serious yeah babe i want to be a
poet
you babe you never told me poetry stuff
yeah i write poetry on the side no
yeah
cool man i've never gone like a roses
are red violets this is why i love
patrick so much i've never got nothing
like that i'm like oh cool you write
poetry i don't know what you read but
great
i said why don't you go do something
with that he says what do you mean let's
find the best poet
professor
in la and we did was a professor at ucla
so don't you go pursue it go find out if
it talks you if it pulls you she went
it's not just your dreams it's your
spouse's dreams babe what are some of
your dreams babe we don't ask those
conversations you know what's the next
dimension
you and your spouse's dreams together
babe how about us one day what do we
want to be one day
oh babe i never thought about that i
know babe what about us
so it's me her
us
then it's a kid we got four kids now i
got a nine seven five and a three week
old by the way just so you guys know
right thank you yes
so
to me
it's my oldest nine-year-old dennis the
seven five then it's the three week old
right so the other day we're driving the
car and i said hey tico dylan i keep
saying tico's name is patrick but
patrick dillon
said yeah daddy i said so
what are you guys going to do long term
you guys going to be in business with
your daddy are we going to do business
together
they look at each other mario you
remember this i'm already somewhere
around here
he says well then that's a pretty deep
question we got to get back to you on
that
yes or no mario where are you i'm like
you got to be i'm like oh i'm sorry yeah
sure you know i'm driving i'm like damn
mario that was a deep response
so 10 minutes later we're still driving
i said that we thought about it what's
that buddy
me and tico are going to start a
business together we want to run
businesses together ourselves that's
what we're going to do but not with you
but we're going to do it ourselves
i'm like
freaking awesome
because it's now your kids dreams now
it's you your spouse and that one
individual kid then it's your kids
together what they're gonna be doing
so when you sit there and you kind of
play and you go to like oh my gosh what
if one day
with the kids running businesses
together and i'm
oh this is gonna feel so freaking
amazing when i was single 23 years old
the girl broke up with me like literally
a legit breakup i deserved to be broken
up but she broke up with me okay
so
guy asked me a question about marriage
does he want to get married i said you
have no idea how about one since i was
six years i wanted to be a dad i want to
be like my dad i love my dad i want to
be him he's my hero right
so i want to get married he says
interesting
i said i tell you one thing here so
what's that i said
i would never let my daughter marry me
at 23. i got work to do meaning me at
23.
so i said
i'm married when i'm ready not right now
i wouldn't let my daughter marry me
that's how i talk to myself right
so this whole conversation about big
houses it has to make sense to me right
like why buy a big house
so i'm sitting there americans like to
do what do you do when the kids come
over there's a party they call it like
hey we're gonna go to the johnson's
house and sleep over whatever it's
called right is that what it is
sleepover right look i'm sorry no no
your dad's still a syrian armenian from
iran we don't do sleepovers
however if they want to do sleepovers at
our house it's totally okay
but it's at our house so i said
i want to have a big house so all of my
friends
my kids friends all want to come to
their house that's how i thought about
it
then christmas you know how christmas
comes in you're kind of like
who do you want to go to for christmas
oh do we go to your parents house or
your parents house
hey you know the kids want to go to your
parents yeah i know but okay
when my kids
have that conversation with their
husband or wife babe guys where do you
want to go we want to go to grandpapa
david papa's house
i visualize that no joke thousands of
times i swear to god i swear to god not
even messing with you
so my house i wanted to create a house
that not only my kids's wife and
husbands come their kids come and all of
their in-laws come
i don't know if you got that i want all
of them to come so that means you need
how big of a house for a legit house
then i still have 20 euros so i'm gonna
get that house because right now the
house i bought is like a 27 million
house i live in right now that house is
gonna be a bigger house all good it's
gonna become a reality god keeps me
healthy it's gonna become a reality
because i went through this formula guys
this is the formula and it gets me so
emotional thinking about it fires me up
when i think about it
and some of us we just live our life hey
cool i'm gonna go to vegas let's go hey
let's go to hawaii this year let's go to
hawaii this year hey babe we're making
pretty good money 224 yeah make more
money than your cousins make more money
than your siblings it's kind of cool
make more money than my dad
the hell is that life all about
what a waste of a life
and you were not put here to just make
220 or 480 or 720
something bigger with you but you got to
ask those tough questions sometimes we
don't ask those questions let me
continue because we're still on the
dreams
by the way for only 9.99 i'm going to
show you how to put you just kidding i
had you
i had you for a minute look at you i
knew he was going to sell something
tonight
okay all right stay with me this is my
vision board it's three of them
the one on the top left you see it took
14 hours for me to put this together the
one in the top four
is what excites me
the one on the top right top left
excites me top right
inspires me and bottom drives me
so top left is dreams
one day i want to live dot dot dot
okay
top right is fire
competition greatness being the best i
want to meet that path and the bottom
one is history
crusade cause
and i created a formula where i go on
20-year runs
i don't go on 90-day runs
i don't like one-year runs i want
20-year runs
now why 20-year runs i'll explain it to
you in a second
so for me everything is visual i have
this painting commission it's in my
house right now used to be my office for
the longest time that's me in the back
by the way this is a 15-foot painting if
you've never seen it's a massive
painting can you name everybody who can
name everybody
who can name it can you actually name
everybody
okay who can name everybody
most people can't name everybody okay
so i'm at the top i'm in the blue suits
you're right so that is tupac
did anybody get tupac by the way yes or
no some of the country people are like
who is that guy yeah that's that's the
guy named tupac not two-pack tupac right
right next to me it's senna ironton
center anybody knows senna the race car
driver
if you don't i named my daughter after
senna her name is senna rose bedavid
same spelling how much i love that guy
the man in the middle is the shah
shaviran when i was born in iran he was
a king
and it's lincoln a republican kennedy a
democrat
einstein
who believes socialism milton friedman
who believes in capitalism mlk whose
approach was very different than tupac
and they're sitting in a bank vault with
a lot of secret hidden messages in there
they're debating two books one of the
books is if you look at the table it's
in rants atlas shrug and the other book
they're debating is karl marx communist
manifesto
that's how messed up my mind is by the
way just so you know that okay
and there's an empty chair and one day
that empty chair will be revealed you
know what this does to me every time i
see it you don't even know what it does
to me what's yours by the way not
telling you to go build something like
this but you got to create these things
when you wake up and see them it fires
you you can't just wing it and put some
stuff up there this takes time to put it
together let me continue
so now driving
for me it's a three-step formula for
everybody here number one is pacing at
what pace you want to go so some of you
guys are like i'm not going to work 16
hour days great that's your pacing some
of you guys may say i'll do 16 hour days
once a week but i'm not going to do it
five days a week that's your pace i'm
only doing 12 hour days no problem i'm
not gonna work more than eight hours a
day no problem i'll go six days a week
great but what's your pace
first question you gotta answer what is
your pace
second one is lifespan for how long are
you willing to go at that pace
for how long one year two years three
years five years i don't know you gotta
answer that then the last one is your
focused effort which means what at the
beginning i have to sell all the time
then it's about recruiting talent then
it's about developing then it's about
raising money so my time changes based
on what face i'm at let me make this
visual for you so hopefully this will
make sense
this is where people win or lose folks
can you tell me what your hardest
working day of the year was
scream out the amount of hours you
worked on the hardest working they say
it on three hang on get that number in
your head your heart is working day of
the year you ready on three everybody
one two three
okay great the hardest working day you
ready
nobody cares about your hardest working
day
what helps you win is your bottom 100
worst working days
don't brag about the day you work so
hard i care about your bottom 100 that's
where you lose
and that's where you win so when you
look at this here's what this is
the top shows four different if you go
to the bottom right the bottom right
shows the one percenter
the 10 percenter the 20 percenter and
the 80 percenter this meeting is called
what eight percent nation right so you
got the one percent 10 20 80
the 80 is the green go look at the
people who are green you see how greens
they work hard they work hard they work
hard and a bad breakup or client cancels
they go all the way down to a one
one setback destroys
those in the 80
the 20
they work hard they work out they go all
the way down to up to nine and a half
meaning they work just as hard as
anybody but once they get a big check of
50 000
they go all the way down to a four
do you see that the ten percent they
work hard work hard work hard nine and a
half and they're worse than six they
still work hard and then you got the one
percent
their best is nine and a half their
worst is eight
so you can't compete with those guys so
again what are the three things pacing
then it's what
span what's the last one focused effort
right pacing span focused effort so now
that's one question you gotta answer the
next one is the following
in this room is it fair to say that some
have more talent than others is that
okay if we say that is that okay if we
said some have more talent than others
yes or no okay how many guys have ever
met an overachiever who's met an
overachiever scream out the over that
you personally know i'm talking about
and your friends and family not like
public you're going to say steve jobs
and you're fr unless if he was your
cousin but anybody in your personal life
okay on three just say his name or her
name over achiever on three one two
three does everybody know he or she was
an overachiever in your community yes or
no
they pretty much know it right so what
is an overachiever somebody that goes
above and beyond what people expected
him to do when you look at this you got
three different types of people the
average the talented the genius
how many guys have somebody that after
school you thought this person was gonna
crush it in life and they did nothing
who knows anybody like that who knows
anybody like that okay you know what
that was
him or her never wanted to know their
capacity they wasted all that talent
happens in sports happens in military
happens in business happens everywhere
fyi
this is a very tough
chart to look at
because some of you guys may leave here
saying i'm a pretty talented guy but
behind closer i'm not gonna lie i'm
pretty lazy and i'm pretty
like i'm not that focused and i like
work hard one month and then i disappear
for six weeks
and eighty percent time i follow
i'm not gonna lie to you like you maybe
let's just say that's the right
everybody here's got a reputation just
so you know some of you guys got a
reputation here how many guys remember
the guy who had a reputation that you
don't want to fight in high school who
knows that guy anybody knows that guy
you don't want to fight johnny he will
knock your ass out yes or no how many
guys do hey you know what that one guy's
got a reputation what's that don't get
your girl too close to him
why why just don't
why he's that charming
really everybody has a reputation just
like you got a reputation of being a
overachiever
and achiever under achiever
all of us will die with one of those
three reputations if it doesn't bother
you don't even worry about the slide but
if this scares the hell out of you well
then do something about it
go do something about it
leave this place saying i am currently
an underachiever let's just say i'm not
gonna go like that
i'm gonna work my way up to be an
achiever achiever means what
you're doing good in life pretty much
everybody thought you were gonna be at
that level but overachievers when they
say i'm gonna lie to you bro i never
thought no joke like one of my friends
adrian love this guy he invites me to
conrad
and we go there nicest guy
he says pat i just have to tell you this
i know none of our friends will tell you
that so what's that he said pat i swear
to god all our parents would talk behind
closed doors because yours was the only
armenian family that got a divorce and
everybody say stay away from pat because
he's going to be the one the biggest
drug dealers and he's going to take all
you guys to jail and i never thought you
can do anything with your life so at
least you said the biggest drug dealer
there's something good about that's the
biggest i take that as a compliment you
know
at least it's the biggest you know may
spend 30 years but you write about man
say this guy was the biggest but the
point is
nobody in high school thought this guy
was going to do anything
i chose one day when i asked those tough
questions so let me wrap this up for
many of you seven ways to reach your
potential number one it must matter to
you if it doesn't you won't do it number
two know the difference between reacting
and initiating many people
are reactors
taxes change you react
your money goes down to 17 000 in a bank
account you react
something happens in your family there's
a loss of loved one they didn't have
insurance you react versus initiate
right big difference find systems that
make you think less and make you more
productive if you don't have systems
like for me
i wanted to have a problem-solving
formula that i can transfer to you where
you can use it yourself that's what i
that's my specialty i want to transfer
that over to where you sit there and say
even after we're talking to todd about
how to take this i think his youtube
channel is going to end up in a million
subscriber channel i think the guys got
the goodies to do something big in the
industry and even more by the way but we
were processing stuff together i can't
help myself that's where i go to i
process things and we go to it right so
you got to find systems so you think
less what does it mean that is think
less i've been walking this entire time
i've been pressing this button i'm not
thinking to press this button i'm just
walking i'm not thinking i'm just doing
it you have systems systems help you
think less and you produce more you have
to think a lot it takes a lot of your
energy away conserve your energy you're
going to need it move on faster
something happens to you move on
normally takes you a week to get over it
do it in three days
normally it takes you three days to get
over it try to do it in one day
normally it takes you one day try to do
it in six hours
normally a bad client pisses breaks your
heart it takes you six hours do it in
two hours it's two hours doing it by the
way just till today i don't like
rejections it just doesn't take me a
week it takes me five seconds
till today look at presidents debating
on stage
they're debating on stage you know and
boom they're going back and forth you
don't feel them getting offended
because they're human beings but they
move on
and they go on to the next one even them
they're not robots none of us are but
you got to move on faster next define
hard work most people don't know what
hard work is
actually define what hard work means put
a number to it
compete up and stop being afraid of
competing people bigger than you
don't be afraid stop competing with
people below you are next to you go up
compete up well at least i'm making more
money than my cousin or my brother or my
sister that's nothing let's compete up a
little bit right if you want to go out
and compete in a marketplace
last couple things before i wrap up why
should someone work for you
or with you
this is a question we rarely ask number
one what benefits
are you currently offering to others by
the way this is not just working for you
as an employee or sales person this is
also working with you as a client why
should someone what benefits do i get
from somebody working with for me
working with you what benefits do you
offer can you actually write those down
you know how many times i've gone
through this myself what benefit i sit
down with the home office employees with
my seven c suite executives what
benefits do we offer guys
we figured out we just had a meeting two
weeks ago in south florida everybody
flew in we had a three days you know
from 7 00 a.m til midnight all we did is
blue ocean strategy on answering these
questions for three straight day after
swot analysis
next
in what way do people improve by
associating with you
if i'm your friend does my life get
better
if i work with you does my life get
better do i make more money how many
lives have you changed positively in the
past year
can you make a list and in what way not
in an arrogant way well what's your
reputation right
what makes your company distinct from
your competition
what separates your leadership style
from others
do you have a code of honor that you
embody do you embody it what benefit
programs will they get from being
associated with somebody like you
these are things that you think about
now let me wrap up here and we bring up
cody here's the last thing i want you to
be thinking about
pre-covet we have different types of
problems to solve
during covet how many guys were like oh
my gosh i have no clue how to overcome
how many guys covet was a
pretty strange time for all of us yes or
no like some problems we have to address
that we never knew how to address right
it's officially post cobit
during covid america printed six and a
half trillion dollars of money just so
you know
forty percent
of all the money ever printed in america
was printed in the last 12 months
let me say one more time please listen
please listen to what i just said
nearly 40 percent of all the money ever
printed in america was printed in the
last 12 months 15 months we've been on
since 17 7 to 245 years
and you know what's crazy
all this money they printed let's give
stimulus to this to that person to this
person
you know what happened no matter who
they gave the money to guess who the
money flowed to
to the rich people
the rich got richer not because they're
bad people because they were ready
because poor people don't know how to
manage their money when it comes to them
there was three types of people
those who just became incred the last
the last nine months
i have made more money the last month
nine months in my entire lifetime
and i've made a lot of money in my
lifetime
i've made more money in the last nine
months than my entire lifetime
okay my entire lifetime why because we
were ready for this season
but i'm gonna tell you this here money
flows so three types of people poor got
poorer rich got richer the people in the
middle who were ready they got richer
there's a lot of new money by the way
some of them are in the room here a lot
of new money but we're officially at
post cobit
everybody here leaves
how you do the next 12 24 36 60 months
will be predicated based on what kind of
strategies you have in place if you do
it right money is going to flow to you
if you don't money is going to flow to
somebody else but if you just go wing in
it don't expect money to come to you all
i'm going to say is if you think money
was made the last five ten years
nothing close to the kind of money
that's gonna be made next 10 20 years if
you go on the right run
having said that thank you so much for
your time everybody appreciate you
[Music]
you